boa tarde
é falar lei por duas vezes boa tarde vão
eu falei duas vezes só porque estiver
alguma outra pessoa com deficiência
visual aqui é importante falar fora do
microfone para a pessoa saber onde eu tô
enfim se aposentando se eu estou em pé é
eu sou a filha do meio de dois irmãos
meus pais tiveram três filhos
eu sou a única que segue completamente
cega e nasci no dia do aniversário do
meu irmão mais velho porque gosta de
causar não é mesmo então já cheguei no
mundo é e aí o meu olho muito vivo acho
que eles não estão vendo mas hoje é o
óculos e talvez dar pra vocês observarem
cara ninguém acredita em mim que eu sou
sério nem os vezes e quando eu saí do
hospital
eu não sou tão velho tenho 26 anos mas
há 26 anos atrás não se exigia o tai chi
e infravermelho que o teste do olhinho a
minha mãe tinha um outro filho meu irmão
como disse na semana do aniversário dele
é e ela percebeu com seis meses que eu
só respondi estímulo visual que tivesse
barulho e quando dava às seis horas da
tarde já estava dormindo e quando o sol
nasce eu estava acordando colocar minha
filha tem alguma alguma peculiaridade
alguma coisa acontece com ela que não
aconteceu com meu filho mais velho eu
fui a vários médicos e todo mundo falava
que eu era louca ela tava vendo coisas
onde não tinha e minha mãe tinha certeza
que é o que ela não era louca e que
alguma coisa tinha de diferente e aí
também vai dizer que eu sou nascida e
criada numa favela no rio de janeiro
chamada cidade alta então eu venho de um
lugar onde não basta a gente ter a
capacidade ea gente precisa ter
oportunidade então eu não tinha plano de
saúde
minha mãe era empregada doméstica meu
pai vendia picolé na praia então não era
assim eu tenho plano de saúde a cada
semana vou levar um hospital é assim
vamos fazer vaquinha para levar ao
hospital e fica três meses na fila pra
ir no hospital do sus pra ver o que que
é natália tem e aí não descobriu não
tinha nada assim eu realmente acho que
não tem nada é segredo pra mim não é
doença
mas não tinha na área e com um ano
eu fui uma médica por indicação e ali a
gente eu fui diagnosticada com miopia no
estádio mais cheio o batismo é alguns de
vocês já a platéia deve ter alguma
dessas três porque são assim coisas
comuns pra quem usa óculos é 223 a a
você tem 223 otávio quase é você
mas a diferença é que meu grupo era
negativo pensando mar ea item acima e
tenha baixo o meu grau e é considerado
abaixo então tinha visão subnormal
hoje em dia a gente chama isso de baixa
visão ou seja hoje eu sei que naquela
época eu chegava a 20% que são vultos
distorcidos como se a gente tivesse
usando óculos escuros à noite eu nunca
vi
detalhe nunca vi formato descobrimos que
natália tinha essas três coisas e foi
como se não tivesse nada assim a minha
infância foi super tranquilo embora eu
trocasse de óculos a cada um ano embora
eu enxergasse - conforme o tempo passava
mas eu brincava de pique esconde tudo
bem que era café com leite
eu tive uma infância muito tranquila
estudou em escola pública regular a vida
inteira e aí eu tive experiências ótimas
com os meus amigos criança e assim eu
fui tanto um background de vivência de
infância muito maravilhoso porque nunca
foi segregado então pra mim eu realmente
não tinha problema nenhum
e aí com 12 anos meu pai ele fez uma
prova ele já tinha sido de tudo na vida
trabalhou em várias lojas enfim e fez
uma prova passou e viu o bombeiro
comecei a tratar no hospital do bombeiro
e aí a gente começou a fazer exames mais
rebuscados parceria com clínicas
particulares e descobriu-se que eu tenho
uma distrofia muito rara na retina
chamada retinose pigmentar sem pigmento
eu sou todo o contrário entendeu não
basta ser uma coisa tem que ser outra
pensa em uma gelatina cheio de furo com
farelo dentro essa é a minha retina e aí
com 12 anos a médica falou pra mim você
sabe braille foi ele quem a não vai
ficar cega taboa
eu falei tá bom como exatamente assim
descobri que ia ficar cega com 12 anos
no mesmo tempo
descobri que eu tinha uma distrofia na
retina sabia nem que era isso saímos do
que do escritório saímos do consultório
a minha mãe meu pai super deprimidos e
dando graças a deus porque eu sabia com
que eu ia lidar daqui pra frente eu
sabia que cada vez de enxergar menos de
uma hora não enxergar nada
é muito complicado quando você tem uma
coisa quando você tem uma coisa mais
você quer vencer mas quer matar sua sede
de saber se não vai conseguir a mesma
coisa aconteceu comigo eu sabia que um
dia conseguir botar água no copo porque
eu vi a água outro dia tinha que botar o
dedo dentro do corpo
eu ia eu andava na rua sozinha eu
conseguia ver os carros e fui perdendo a
visão periférica então hoje barraca
imagina o quanto de roxo que não tinha
no meu corpo eu precisava lidar com
concreto ea cegueira pra mim era mais
concreto que eu tinha e pra mim ser cega
nunca foi um problema o problema não é
meu problema da sociedade que não está
preparada para atender às necessidades
que eu tenho
então tudo bem ficar cega que bom
com 12 anos dos 12 aos 15 eu aprendi a
ler em braile
eu li uns 300 livros porque a gente já
tinha uma condição de vida melhor e aí
eu comprei uma lupa que se passava em
cima do livro e aparecia na televisão é
enorme então tudo que tinha de livro
para ler o livro três anos passaram e eu
confio em uma festa de 15 anos linda
15.018 do meu irmão lembrou eu de
vestido de gala e meu irmão de bermuda e
sandália foi lindo a nossa valsa e aí
foi lindo
e aí três meses depois eu fiquei como é
completamente cega falei mãe história um
champanhe e amanhã meu filho e dançando
porque minha mãe sabia e eu não de todos
os problemas que viriam depois eu fiz
uma prova para uma escola técnica e
passei em primeiro lugar comprasse
técnico em administração
daí eu cheguei numa escola 3.500 alunos
ea única cega
aí eu falei 'gente oi tudo bem eu sou
cega professor a ele eu não recebo
pagando por uma pessoa cega e já começou
né
vários embates assim é vários gente para
o suíço sempre porque o problema nunca é
do outro problema não é meu problema
sempre
o outro então o problema não era ele
agora eu chegar ele tem uma língua
diferente mas eu vi isso em vários
lugares porque sempre fui a primeira
sempre bate à porta e falei tudo bem não
está preparado vamos preparar vou te
ajudar
não é sobre isso é só você está aberto e
encontra algumas pessoas abertas algumas
pessoas fechadas mas eu conseguir fazer
com que o bichinho da acessibilidade
mordesse e outras não outras pessoas não
querem me ver nem pintada continuo
achando que eu sou uma farsa porque meu
é muito vivo e por que não haja
problemas nenhuns e sangue
mas aí fiz esse curso técnico tinha 22
matérias com conteúdo não adaptado e
tudo bem eu estudava com o inspetor
estava com porteiro todo mundo que
passava na minha fala foi tudo bem pode
ler aqui pra mim que daqui a 20 minutos
eu tenho uma prova não era
não foi por isso que eu não estudei que
eu não me formei fui muito bem e me
formei o técnico em administração na
escola eu tocava gaita eu fechei a tudo
que tinha pra fazer na escola eu
arrumava para as pessoas ficarem
correndo já vem aquela louca querendo
fazer tudo eu ia estava lá eu natália
mas me formei técnica e aí com 18 anos
eu me vi com o primeiro problema por ser
cega sim porque além do curso técnico
que eu fazia vários outros cursos
mas aí me vi com 18 anos tendo que bater
na porta das empresas para pedir estágio
e aí não conseguir meu diploma de curso
técnico porque embora eu fosse uma
técnica tecnólogo em administração super
capaz como é a maior série da turma eu
sou cega e daí não só qualificar da sua
categoria é não conseguir estágio fazer
trabalho voluntário
morava em uma favela como eu disse no
rio de janeiro já tinha mudado de uma
favela pra outra uma muito maior tinha
um monte de madeira mas bati num jornal
comunitário chamado a voz das
comunidades falei cara quero trabalhar
que me deixa fazer qualquer coisa eu fui
pra lá fazia texto batia na porta da
porta das pessoas para fazer cadastro
que dois anos assim que se não entrar em
depressão imagina eu me sentindo super
capaz e as pessoas não acreditam em mim
eu sou humana como eu falei antes eu só
pessoa tem sentimento é muito ruim você
ter a sua capacidade colocada em prova
por uma condição
o que você tem só porque eu sou cego
como você não me contratar porque eu sou
negra porque eu sou mulher eu sei o que
acontece
e aí eu nunca sei que comigo é por qual
das barreiras assim se é porque eu sou
cega se é porque eu sou mulher e eu não
sei pode ser pelas três coisas um pacote
não é deus caprichou quando me fez com
todos mas tenho orgulho das três coisas
inclusive e aí fiquei dois anos assim
como 20 anos eu falei caramba isso ganha
dinheiro entender meu pai precisa parar
de trabalhar minha mãe não estava em
casa a cada 15 dias
não tá dando mais é e aí comecei a
redistribuir o meu currículo
meu currículo chegou na globo dona
prestadora de serviço que é let e aí eu
fui chamada para fazer a oficina de
programa de auditório tinha que ver a
caravana que combinava com os programas
daí escolhi a caravana
o ônibus é o que as pessoas vão comer
todo um trabalho logístico que eu tinha
aprendido no curso técnico de tl
produção qualidade logística então
estava pronta
eu falei me dá uma oportunidade eu vou
provar que sou capaz
entrei para trabalhar nessa empresa
terceirizada fiquei três meses foi
efetivada graças a deus não fica aí que
tá bem eu falei o va e aí é o meu irmão
pediu na internet
a regina casé pra ir no programa dela no
twitter e ele conseguiu eu fui com ele
chegou lá tinha um livro em braile no
programa porque o programa tinha uma
biblioteca regina pergunta quem ler
livro em braille que levanta a mão aí eu
levantei a mão e ela veio até mim falou
mas por que você lembrar ele faz algum
trabalho vai ser a professora não porque
eu sou cega ela como assim você sabe eu
falei assim sem enxergar
enxergo nada meio de max e aí ela fosse
você olhou muito vivo eu falei mas a
minha visão não é
e aí ela começou a entrevistar enfim
vale começou toda a minha história é
profissional né
no final do programa ela vai perguntar o
que eu fazia da vida
olha eu estou trabalhando mas é preciso
de oportunidade porque ninguém acredita
que eu sou capaz ela não você super
capaz como você não é capaz que é
portanto um macho vamos fazer também uma
bota pra trabalhar que eu vou te mostrar
que eu sou mais capaz ainda e aí no
programa seguinte ela me chama para
reconhecer um quadro de tarsila do
amaral eu sou apaixonada pela semana de
arte moderna e ela botou uma barulho na
minha frente eu fui linda
quase que eu reproduzi aquela espera de
pagamento e aí ela todos nós vamos como
sempre a gente enxerga com a mão você
como eu com a mão não tem diferença
nenhuma tô vendo a mesma forma eu
consegui é me preparar e foi o que eu
falei acima de todas as maneiras me
cerquei de preparo
eu sabia que do lugar de onde eu vinha
não bastava ter capacitação e mérito e
precisava ter oportunidade
mas se eu tivesse oportunidade não
tivesse pronta nada adiantar e aí eu
encerrei meu contrato na let enquanto
terceira
o esquenta voltou porque esquenta no
programa de temporada e aí não você não
vem trabalhar comigo e eu fui pro palco
como comentarista de acessibilidade e
para os bastidores trabalha como
pesquisador redator
ali descobri minha vocação eu sou
apaixonada por pessoas eu amo escrever
eu sou muito curiosa muito detalhista e
aí vou fazer jornalismo porque sou
comunicóloga comecei a fazer faculdade
de jornalismo quero apresentar jornal
mesmo na televisão e aí problema como
você segue a valer pelo um ser querido
da empresa que vai ter que se preparar
sei que estou pronto a empresa que se
prepara para receber e assim eu me
formei na verdade não foi assim não foi
tão fácil assim
eu e meu sonho de dar uma faculdade
muito cara no rio de janeiro não tinha
condições de passar na porta sabe aquela
coisa que você vê aquela loja pode
ganhar não é uma roupa tem que passar do
outro lado que se você possa perto você
não consegue nem sabe não tinha aquela
coisa do imã a da atração não
tem porque a faculdade era muito cara aí
eu fui numa outra faculdade tão
maravilhosa quanto o fmi lá no rio
bati na porta e foi tudo bem o meu nome
é natália essa é a história da minha
vida eu quero estudar aqui mas eu não
tem como pagar nem 10% dessa mensalidade
e aí foi recebido por uma pessoa
maravilhosa que falou olha mas a gente
não dá bolsa família mas me dá uma
oportunidade aí aquela coisa que eu
falei ao time dá uma oportunidade
ela deixou fazer uma prova eu arrebentei
na prova ela falou bolsas rua e aí eu
comecei em janeiro em fevereiro de 2014
fazer jornalismo da espm no rio
e aí também não foi fácil a gente
aprendeu muito junto porque quando você
chega num lugar em que não está
preparada para receber o diferente não
por força de vontade mas por não têm
hábito por não ter gente diferente por
todo mundo que estou lhes é igual a
gente aprendeu muito assim a gente se
conheceu muito espm a gente agora íntima
assim eu ia mas foi uma uma jornada
eu quero jogar tudo pro alto não aguenta
mais porque além disso como se não
bastasse eu tinha dois empregos
eu já trabalhava na globo como
comentarista pesquisadora e aí eu fui
trabalhar na globo news que é uma
produtora de reportagem repórter viajei
o brasil inteiro fazendo um documentário
de expressão cultural de juventude de
preferir um novo gigante mas basicamente
eu tinha aqui nas periferias da praça da
globo encontrar o que a galera da minha
idade estava fazendo pra sobreviver e
foi uma experiência muito bacana porque
foi é um dos primeiros lugares em que eu
fui contratado enquanto profissional
capaz pouco é botavam a minha
deficiência envolve inclusive eles até
esqueci eu tinha que falar é isso aí não
consigo não tá isso aí vai ter que dar
um suporte porque a pessoa que não
enxerga mesmo é verdade olhando mas não
tá vendo
e assim eu viajei o brasil inteiro foi
uma experiência incrível é eu cresci
muito amadureci muito eu me descobri
enquanto pessoa eu aprendi a cair eu me
permitia fazer muitas coisas em que eu
não me permitia antes porque é isso
assim são três rótulos em que me foi
colocada e nunca tive problema com o
rótulo
acho que os rótulos são importantes para
saber o que a gente quer que a gente é
não tem como a gente na farmácia não tem
um nome do remédio não tem como abrir
uma geladeira no teu nome do
refrigerante
só que a maneira como a gente recebe o
rótulo depende muito
às vezes você está comendo a comida que
tudo isso é que é um representante
daquele bem gelado e aí o refrigerante
bem quente eo cara não desce b são joão
estão importante a gente tem que saber
lidar com eles em 2016
o meu contrato na globo terminou eu
estava no sétimo período da faculdade eu
precisava fazer estágio e aí meu amigo
mesmo com todo o meu currículo eu
continuo sendo categoria não pessoa
qualificada não conseguia estar de novo
porque só uma pessoa cega mas aí cara eu
movi o seu eu falei não vou perder minha
graduação distribuir meu currículo no
meio que eu tinha uma professora da espm
fez uma carta de recomendação e mandou
no meio dela e aí o meu currículo chegou
na coca cola que a empresa que o
trabalho hoje uma multinacional e aí eu
fui chamada para trabalhar lá para
trabalhar fazer uma entrevista e aí o
cara falou assim olha a gente realmente
nunca trabalhou com pessoas cegas mas
estou aqui província história
eu falei não só precisa de uma
oportunidade vai daqui está fazendo meu
contrato
ele não fica assim porque pode não rolar
eu não quero causar uma expectativa que
ele não tem certeza
e aí contei um pouco da minha vida
profissional uma semana depois eu fui
convida conversar com uma
vice-presidência mas depois eu estava
trabalhando da coca cola como estagiária
e eu tô há desde dezembro trabalhando
como trainee já passei por três áreas
agora o trabalho na área de relações
corporativas é e está sendo assim uma
experiência que também já crescendo
enquanto pessoa muito assim enquanto
profissional não tem nem como dizer né
eu só tô trabalhando na coca-cola gente
pensa nunca pensei você pensava eu só
tomava coca cola uma vez por mês na vida
quando eu era criança e agora
trabalhando entendendo tudo o que
acontece por dentro é eu queria deixar
pra vocês de mensagem que assim para
além de tudo todas as dificuldades que
eu tenho na vida que eu ainda tenho por
que por exemplo não pago conta tá quem
paga as minhas contas não é meu pai e
andar na rua é muito complicado
e fazer compras pela internet ainda é
muito complicado mas eu não aceitei um
lugar que me colocaram é às vezes é
muito a gente é muito pressionado de
todas as maneiras eu acho que mesmo que
eu não fosse deficiente eu ia tá aqui
pra contar uma história pra vocês só que
de maneira diferente
o que importa é a força de vontade que a
gente tem
o que a gente quer fazer a gente tem que
ter porque como disse fábio como dizia
que parou e aí depois a gente vai
desenvolver o como o povo eu também não
sei como eu faço muita coisa mas eu sei
que eu tenho por que o topo da montanha
que vocês vêem o toco e eu sei que é
algo que eu sei que vou ter que escalar
a montanha para chegar ali então a frase
que eu sempre deixo é fácil sabendo que
você nunca vai fazer nada igual a
ninguém porque nós não somos iguais mas
que você vai fazer
não sei como mas você vai fazer o que eu
fiz
então todo mundo faz
[Música]